to the raiders 24 hours ago the las
vegas raiders said they were focused on
the field not what what coach john
gruden wrote in an email years ago then
more emails more inappropriate comments
and now gruden is out the new emails
were revealed by the new york times last
night they document a series of
controversial and offensive comments
gruden resigned last night and he did
apologize for his actions the raiders
interim head coach is rich bustach
biscachia he's been coaching for 40
years and he's been the raiders special
teams coach for four seasons gruden's
downfall is a major setback certainly
for the las vegas raiders but what
impact is there on las vegas effort to
be a major sports city the continuing
effort hector mejia live this afternoon
from allegiant stadium with that part of
the story hector
hitler i spoke with clark county
commissioner michael naftering an lvcva
board meeting earlier this morning nafta
represents this area the district where
the allegiance stadium sits on in his
opinion raiders owner mark davis took
quick action and made the right decision
by accepting john gruden's resignation
monday the new york times published more
negative emails from now former raiders
coach john gruden he reportedly used
homophobic racist and derogatory slurs
and emails dating back to 2011 the new
york times reported it happened for
several years gruden resigned late
yesterday this morning i also spoke to
las vegas mayor carolyn goodman about
the controversy she hopes more people
learn learned something from this
i don't think mark davis had any choice
and certainly coach rudin had no choice
but to resign it was inappropriate and
embarrassing and
hurtful to so many disappointing when
you have quick turnover like that but i
think this will have no impact on all
the excitement that's happening in the
legion stadium both with the raiders and
otherwise it's an incredible venue it's
been really exciting to get it filled up
to capacity
gruden's comments came under fire on
friday after the first email was made
public and the team now doing its best
to avoid any distractions as they head
to denver to face the broncos this
sunday reporting outside of legion
stadium hector mejia live local now